when I watched this film I thought to
myself wow a movie about a politician
who on at least one issue actually
evolves in his thinking was that part of
the appeal for you Rob and bringing this
story to the screen I have a different
take on it okay I mean I don't think he
evolved and this is you know we've had
long discussions we've all had long
discussions but I've spent time talking
to Doris Kearns Goodwin about this who
worked with Lyndon Johnson and you know
she went down to the ranch and wrote his
biography you know worked with him on it
also you know Bill Moyers who was his
press secretary and Ben Barnes you know
who was a lieutenant governor of Texas
who spent a lot of time with Lyndon
Johnson you cannot do what he did in
terms of not just civil rights but the
Voting Rights Medicare Medicaid
headstart all these programs that he put
together you don't do that on a dime you
have to look at Johnson in a bigger
picture in a bigger light he he grew up
in poverty he grew up in in the hill
country of West Texas and he knew what
poverty was he taught at schools
impoverished schools and so when he puts
when he put forth this war on poverty
the Great Society
you don't just cook that up you don't
just turn on a dime and do that that's
something that has to be somewhere in
your DNA it may have been pushed down
and it certainly was because he knew he
was also a consummate politician and he
knew what could get done and what
couldn't get done but the antecedents of
that had to be there somewhere and he
never thought of himself as a southerner
he never did he thought of himself as a
Texan and a westerner and he was more
than happy to take on the mantle of
being a southerner if that would help
him broker deals like he says in the
film I'm the only one who could speak
southern and Kennedy you know you know I
don't know how much she spoke Kennedy
but but but he was able to broker do
and he knew how it worked and when he
was screaming in there about you put
this bill on the floor that of the
Congress it will never become law he
knew that for a fact and I we had an
interesting conversation with some
journalists and I found out after the
fact because where that was an argument
to could pen Kennedy have ever passed it
or did it take Kennedy dying and the
consummate knowledge of how to work the
the the the the Congress like like
Johnson did and we talked to some
reporters who did cover the Capitol Hill
at that time he said no way in a million
years would it have ever gotten out of
even gotten out of committee the Civil
Rights Act and Johnson knew that it
couldn't get passed but I would suggest
that you do not spend the amount of
political capital that he spent in order
to get it done he knew he could get it
done once Kennedy died because he liked
he said you're frightened to presidents
now and he figured that out but he also
knew he was gonna spend an enormous
amount of political capital to get it
done meaning he was gonna lose the
southern democrats and he said it for a
decade and he turns out it's more than
five decades and so you don't do that
lightly knowing full well that that
could happen to you and it could
actually sink your presidency so I don't
think he turned on a dime
I think his political the political
landscape he evolved with that but I
don't think he evolved in terms of what
he thought was right at a certain point
in time man I'm intrigued to ask you as
someone who's not from this country what
do you make of the kind of decades of
partisanship that we learn you know in
this film we're going on then are going
on now how do you find it all I mean you
know this moment in history was an
incredible moment in history you know
what's going on now is just getting
worse and worse and I think his film
obviously you can look at it and see a
president who could get things done and
I think that's what in retrospect we all
look back at Johnson and see he's one of
his great strength
so you know it's a hard question for me
us like a do you know what what's my
opinion of what's going on now I mean
it's [ __ ] crazy and I think many
Americans feel that and I don't think
Rob feels that way I think he knows
what's going on oh I mean if you have we
at the Twitter account you know I'm
pretty I'm pretty even-keeled on on this
subject but you know look you know it's
it's pretty evident what's going on now
but you know obviously this old drew us
to this material and this president he
was one of the great presidents who you
know ultimately got into deep with
Vietnam but was you know pure politician
and could get stuff done Liz I want to
ask you about Woody Harrelson because I
feel like this is one of the best
performances I've ever seen him give and
I thought to myself as I was watching it
wow he must have just been the epitome
of focus on the set and then I saw a
video on James Marsden's
Instagram today of him in full LBJ
makeup and wardrobe basically doing this
dance boogie so so what was he like he
did a lot of research for the role and
he studied Johnson's recordings which
the library had and he really you know
he became Lyndon Johnson transformed
himself but he was he's always
good-natured and fun to be around and
and nothing got too heavy on the set
ever we had a really good time with him
for Tim and Trevor were you guys
particularly intrigued as brothers by
the fraternal relationship between Bobby
and John Kennedy because that to me was
very eye-opening to see the rifts
between the two of them and their
differences in thinking what was it like
to explore that with this film I don't
think I ever really thought about that
but it makes a lot of sense I mean I
think Tim and I have always been drawn
to to the Kennedys in particular
actually I was long more interested in
Bobby and Jack before Johnson and I
think I think when when we I think it
was a Robert Kerr or it was an excerpt
from the his most recent book in The New
Yorker that really like got me thinking
about this guy in a different light and
and
you know I think there's something quite
Shakespearean about both Johnson and his
relationship with the Kennedys and the
Kenny's relationships with with each
other which was really interesting to
explore as we started developing it yeah
and I imagine it must have been very
difficult Jeffrey Donovan does a great
job as JFK I don't know the actor's name
who played Bobby he's great
those are Michael stall David though
those roles must have been among the
hardest to figure out how to cast I
would imagine I mean yeah you know I
think that like it's always one of the
most daunting things really when you're
perusing a movie about you know JFK and
Bobby who's just you know how do you
cast the actors who are sort of not
gonna be you know just like cheesy or
sort of make people laugh at them really
for trying to play these people who sort
of everyone know so well you know in the
accents and everything and I think like
both of them just we feel like you know
Jeffrey Ward the back brace you know
every day he was obsessed with the back
brace he was even unless opposed he
always had it on and I want to just say
something about Tim and Trevor because
they you know they they developed the
script with Joey heartstone it was a
terrific writer and Liz Gloucester says
to me you know you should read this you
know I mean and I said I don't want to
make a movie about LBJ I mean I you know
I hated the guy I was of draft age you
know during the Vietnam War and that's
all I thought about you know I think
he's a bad guy I thought more about him
and I thought okay you know I've spent
time in politics and policy
I work in California government okay I
can see he it was like a tale of two
presidencies you know if you didn't have
the Vietnam War you'd have one of the
great presidents of all time you can't
separate it but you know legislatively
except you know maybe next to FDR
probably the greatest ever but what I
really liked about what these guys did
and you know you got you just mentioned
it they saw this article it was by Carol
in The New Yorker and it was this sliver
time it was basically about what happens
to this guy when he has to assume the
presidency and the pressure that's on
him to become president from and take
over from a beloved president and
somebody he felt he could never live up
to they would never love him they would
never accept him and that's what I
thought was the window into why to do
this because to me if you want to do a
biography of Lyndon Johnson you need
1012 hours on Netflix or Amazon or
something to really explore it but I
said who is this guy who is this guy
that had these two presidencies and one
I hated and one we all have come to love
and we've all benefited from these from
these programs and that was the window
in that little sliver there said okay
this a real personality of a guy comes
out when he's under the most pressure of
the most difficult circumstances and the
the the Doris Kearns Goodwin book gave
us a couple of real clues as to who he
was one was he had a recurring nightmare
of being paralyzed and I thought that's
interesting here you got a guy who's
everybody thinks he's an arm twisting
bull in the china shop he gets what he
wants and look at this he's feeling
paralyzed and then the other thing was
his relationship to his mother which was
conditional his mother he felt his
mother wouldn't love him unless he was
doing the thing she wanted him to do so
he felt at times unloved and was unsure
of that I said that's who this guy is
and that's what I think the public
doesn't know about this guy
so we had all that and I think it was
the the finiteness of the timeframe that
allowed us to explore that because
otherwise it kind of gets lost in in you
know all of that so I think that's what
makes it work and I'm sure you all
noticed in the credits this was shot on
location in DC New Orleans and Dallas
Tim and Trevor are there restrictions
that Dallas puts on a film production
when you want to shoot the motorcade
route are you allowed to shoot the
actual route or do they limit that so we
did actually shoot the real route I mean
it it was definitely a little bit
complicated and we
she shot the whole thing in I mean I
want to say like five six hours was fine
dealing possum you know well what I've
hours and we shot right there in Dealey
Plaza and I had to call the the mayor of
Dallas because they weren't going to
give us that and he said that you can
have it for six hours because they don't
want it tying up traffic for the whole I
believe it was eight but you shot it in
cities oh well they had they had told
you because three weeks prior that James
Franco show on Hulu had shot there it
was forever and they just ruined it I
think the city was like we can't let
this happen again and we had already
scheduled our shoot and they were like
sorry guys the point is we had a very
short window and I had four cameras and
so I thought well in the time that we
have to reset all the extras and reset
the motorcade maybe I could get them to
go three times around you know and I
figured well that's twelve angles so
that should be enough and then we very
carefully picked the angles that we
wanted and we got everybody ready and I
actually we actually dressed the guy up
to look like Abraham Zapruder and gave
him a camera is a digital camera but you
couldn't see he was off in the distance
and he stood exactly where Abraham
Zapruder was and if you notice in the in
the film you know when the car comes out
from behind the sign that's a shot that
you can see in this a pruder film and
the thing that was that's interesting
about I don't know how many people have
been to Dealey Plaza but what's
interesting about it it first of all
it's tiny when you think about what
happened you know what happened a
monumental thing that happened there but
the other thing is there's always these
history buffs and sickens conspiracy
buff they're all there they're always
there no matter when whether that's a
production or not so you got like
built-in consultants you know no no no
the umbrella man stood over there the
babushka lady was over there and we had
a lot of people telling us well I thank
all five of you for being here and I
congratulate you on this specific